that's that's how you want
to yeah no burping even worse well live
good afternoon good evening and welcome
to Sidra your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel hello and welcome also to the
solo one sci-fi podcast special yeah we
we're on both channels oh my God the
modern technology is marvelous uh we are
rating the second of the Star Trek
movies The Wrath of
con
um I have a big question to ask at the
end of this video about the wrath of KH
but first of all we'll just quickly run
through the rating the rating system
that we're using once again yes you're
probably better explaining it than I am
so if you don't mind right saying how we
again I invented it did completely
invented I'm just turning off my screen
screen something hey Dave how are you
sir um right so we have the Kirk rating
which is action how much action is there
we have the Spock rating how logical is
the movie and the story we have the
checkoff rating does this film embody
Star Trek's
values um original Star Trek values not
the modern Star Trek values because
nobody knows what that is no we have the
bones rating is it funny mainly because
me and you generally think the bones is
one of the funniest characters yes yeah
I agree um we have the Scotty rating
which is 10 and Science and the
technology of the um the show you know
in this one it's going to be like the
Genesis thing and stuff yeah there's a
dog going crazy somewhere okay my my
anyway um we have the Aur rating which
is how well it's written and we have the
seven of nine rating because she's the
most beautiful woman that's ever lived
and it's about the visuals how does the
film look what's it look like what's the
style of the film ET okay that's right
there we go and then on that we have the
final we have the rodenburgh rating
which is the overall score doar score
put together divided by four divided by
themselves we've already done the motion
picture and I rated that at 2.57 was my
rbur rting and you rated it at
2.12 so it didn't massively score well
but I scored it a little bit better than
yours um what did I score it better on
basically just the check off rating I
said I I said the rate the value Star
Trek values are a little bit higher than
you other than that no so that's right
the wrath of
KH the wrath of KH said the Wrath we say
the Wrath like ra if you're in North if
you're Northern you know say path and
Daft and stuff would you say wrath say w
it's the wrath of can it's the WRA of
[Music]
right um let's let's kick straight off
with the um with the Kirk rating for for
the motion pi picture we both scored it
too and because it's
boring yes
um Kirk rating for The Wrath of
KH let's let's throw out our scores
straight away and then explain them
right so I'm gonna tell you straight off
I've rated it five five out of five
that's that's five Chevrons if we were
going to St G yeah so it's it's it's
pretty locked but of course you need
seven for that um maxed it
uh what I wrate it
I I think I'd probably give it a
four because um there is a lot of action
um but I know there other the Tre movies
which had perhaps a little bit more
action um there are quite a few scenes
where they're on the bridge and they're
talking to each other on their various
Bridges and stuff like that um but no it
had a lot of action it was great um I
think I'll give it a four okay right so
I'm going five out of five basically
because I think this has genuinely one I
mean is limited by the technology but
I'm not going to um I'm I'm going to say
that that for what was available at the
time CGI Etc at the time um I I'm going
to take that into account okay it's one
of the greatest Space Battles at the end
of that um film that I've ever seen
nebula yes well yeah it's been repeated
a million times yeah it's genuinely
tense it's genuinely
like kill him shoot um raise the shields
you bloody idiot which we'll discuss
that in a bit when we talk about logic
and stuff
um
it's again it
just I think it was just something we
quite hadn't quite seen before um
it's it's just clever you've got the
whole bit at the end as well with Spock
um sacrificing himself which I which is
again it's one of those things that's
been done a million times before but at
the time was sort of like they've killed
the main
character and we didn't know about the
Search for Spock at that point so it was
like you know I remember watch think a
factor I think a factor about this film
which also makes it even better is going
back to the comparison for the first
movie where the P was so different the
feel of the whole of the first Tre movie
was so different that this made a good
film even better based on the standards
of the first movie and also it also
brought back a lot of the remembrance of
all the best episodes of classic track
we even had a classic character return
and to get that all back with the you
know with the actual cast and the actors
and the and the characters are much
older and how you know they're starting
to sort of think about middle age and
what they've done and what they've
achieved um I think that's another
Factor which gave it a really good sort
of um benefit and as you say the the
action Factor was a very good one so I
think that's one of its benefits I
actually think this film is it
remembered to be a Star Trek film yeah
as well whereas the first one was trying
to be space odyssey1 space odyssey it
was it was um this goes back to some of
the uh modern iterations where people
try to make Star Trek that they just
don't get it the people who made the
wath K they got it they know what it was
it's always hard to Define what it is
that makes Star Trek let's say as any
franchise if you're a big fan the fans
know what gets it what makes it and a
lot of these things don't but no they
really did get it right and yeah they
had the right balance in this between
story yeah you know um it had a story
that was
genuinely
um you know sort of believable as well
in that you can completely understand
that that from his character that that
KH would completely blame Kirk even
though it wasn't really Kirk's fault
100% blamed him and like I said like
they you never came back and checked on
us and you know it's like well yeah why
didn't nobody go back and check on him
so thing and why didn't everybody check
that they were all right you know that
they speculate about returning back they
did speculate going back to C alha 5 um
in the original episode but it didn't
obviously never happened and then there
was this big um solar flare or whatever
it was it caused CTI Alpha 5 to yeah and
it destroyed CTI Alpha
sorry yeah whatever set whatever it was
yeah um but but yeah so well let's let's
let's talk about that a little bit
because in the next section we've got
Spock rating which is logic okay um I
struggled with this a little
bit because there's two I have two big
problems with the logic of the movie
okay one the setti
alpha five moving
that's not that's not really but it
doesn't make sense that when the
spaceship when the Grom arrived they
didn't know that because they'd have
star charts and they'd have the planets
they when they turned up they would go
that planet's moved there's there's one
less than there was before that's right
because they said yeah C Al 6 was
apparently exploded it didn't actually
elaborate how and why it exploded that
you say they would have been able to
plot chart for this city Alpha system oh
we reached out hang on a minute there's
one planet uh less than in our records
and it wasn't picked up at all and uh
CTI ala 5 was in a different pos
position as you say so yeah that doesn't
exactly follow logic it is a plan it is
a system that had been surveyed before
yes because the Enterprise had been
there when they dropped them off that's
right so so that's a bit of a bit of a
plth hole but not massive it's just an
error
um we mentioned last week we talking
about um Czech off Czech off shouldn't
have recognized Khan he wasn't in the
episode he wasn't in the episode unless
obviously he might have seen photos or
that you know read the report or
whatever but it was a little bit of
surprise when he but he he recognized
the botony bay but he could have read
the report it would have been it could
have been I mean the real life is that
the um check off didn't start on the
show until series two or season two and
of course um the the first C episode was
in season one some people have said that
maybe he was just um you know um
mooching around the cargo bay or just
you know what I mean he couldna be doing
anything and he just did we just didn't
see him big crew big crew could been you
know what I mean so so yeah all like you
said it's in the reports or whatever so
again not a major problem from a logic
of the episode though I actually do
question whether the Federation would
have ever developed the Genesis torpedo
yeah it was pretty
dangerous I mean it's a horrendously
dangerous weapon yeah um I can
completely understand the benefits to it
you know you can terraform a planet
instantly oh gosh yeah I mean it in
principle it's a very very uh as as a an
entity of science than the Federation
would
be interested in creating something like
that because they're always expanding um
and of course in Star Trek you've had
planets which are being terraformed the
normal way which takes decades and
decades and this thing like just far as
a thing bang 10 minutes later you got a
class M Planet you know it's but as you
say it was um it was also it was quite
early in its project it was they had
different phases of it they had one
where they did the phase which was
underground which we saw with um with
Carol Marcus and then of course but when
the missile was fired at the end of star
Tre of of star Tre 2 because of the um
it's on the transport P whatever it
maybe it wasn't properly configured
which is why it like um um when it
actually didn't um it wasn't a planet
either was it was actually a nebula
didn't it launch fire into a nebula but
wa it no but it oh I don't know actually
the nebula was then turned into a planet
I think is the oh you know what I've
never thought I I assumed that the it
was a planet in the nebula
well that's that was the problem there's
it didn't it there was no well it
shouldn't have been a star even though
stars do exist in nebula that's what I
was gonna say you can get stars in nebul
can't you the the torpedo was
transported off to save the ship it
wasn't beam they didn't say it was
beamed to a planet or anything they just
said it was beamed away and then they
tried to leg it yeah um and they just
about escaped didn't they before the it
explosion yeah it went off you're right
yeah about that see a planet so my
assumption was always that it's that the
planet was created by the Genesis
weapon even not 100% certain that makes
sense either so that's again if we've
got a logic point of view I think they
just I don't know if they just didn't
bother um you know regular one the pl um
you know regular one yeah what's the
regular one um that astal that that was
orbiting wasn't that what became the
Genesis planet that would make sense so
it would be the um the object they were
on so they beamed it down and maybe it
was just that it was beamed down close
enough that's what I think I think it
might have been although I don't know I
don't know they just they just don't say
in the film no they don't don't you know
what they did that would have been
really easy just go beam it down to the
planet surface and then leg it and but
they don't but I suppose it would have
took away from the from the thing of the
the movie you know kind of too muching
and all that sort of stuff um but also
when it detonated maybe you could have
seen it but I suppose again that was
because it was done from distance so
that you see the Enterprise you do see
what looks like a planet forming and
like I said I think that was regular one
well you see the nebula sort of
disappear don't you yeah but then after
that you see a scene of a planet like in
its early stages yeah that's why I
always wondered if it was the nebula I
don't know that's a very good question I
never I can see you're where you're
coming from
but as you say it was never very clear
so I suppose in my brain that's how
planets actually do form though but you
know longer period neb that's maybe
where I've always got it from so um I've
given it a four out of five for logic
just because I think there are those
couple of issues but and a
positive the whole thing with um Khan
wanting the revenge and actually the way
the the story
developed is logical is there's no major
problems with the with the way the story
is written for me um and um even down to
but I'm I'm I think I'm being a bit
forgiving because um even down to sort
of the way they captured the Grom they
don't explain it it just happened and
you're like where's the security team on
this ship and the fact that Kirk doesn't
raise the shields when the gom's
approaching doesn't really make sense
Stanley agrees with you there that it
was the it was the regulus planet I
think it was it wasn't don't think it
was a planet that was an asteroid it was
asid or planetoid whatever the term is
but it was yeah it was a moon I think it
was like a big moon or something um I
suppose to my rating um obviously we'
talked about this but I suppose
really um out of
five I'll I'll just give it a three
similar to you um like I said there was
some things I think that the check off
thing um it wasn't a big deal but it
does really stand out a mile that we
need have never met KH and obviously
like I said I think the Genesis devised
like you said it was a bit of a dodgy
thing in logic really so well when we
talk about the check off rating we're
we're smashing through these this week
such a good bloody good film there um
I'm going to stret off the bat say with
the check off rating I'm giving it a
three for Star Trek values values this
is the values one okay I don't think
the Federation would develop the Genesis
weapon the Genesis device because I
think they would consider that to be way
too dangerous I I don't think they would
ever allow them to do it um not not to
the extreme because you remember this
this weapon obliterates everything in
its path because I mean that's what
they're looking for it they're looking
for a planet and it can't even have
microbes on yeah nothing at all
completely dormant so I love the way
they explain that because they're saying
like like you know we would create this
weapon because we're only going to use
it for this and we're going to be very
careful and not even microbes can be on
the on the thing with so so it's fine
but I just don't I can't see the
Federation ever given permission for
this I'm going to slightly disagree for
the simple reason that there are so many
there are so many planets out there
which don't have any life at all and
space is big and if you got all these
ships that can go to Sol systems all
over the place within a very short time
there's going to be a lot lot lot more
of uh places where which are from what
they gather completely dormant of life
or any chances of life um and I think if
they had had more of a time to actually
um have conduct experiments refine it
get it a bit more stable and a bit more
um in a way where they've got more
control and there's less um side effects
and negativity from it so I would
probably give the values slightly higher
than you I think so you go three I would
give a four I think just slightly only
because of the size of space and how
many dormant planets you make a good
point and and I say the guys in the in
the um in the comments make the same
point really they it wasn't designed as
a weapon it's a it's a tool and the
Federation like you said is growing so
quickly they need real estate yes and
that's do this device does for me like
say I just I just think that what
there's so many other technologies that
the
Federation wouldn't develop because they
um considered it the long-term effect
sort of things they put themselves at a
disadvantage regularly in the Federation
that I I don't think they personally
would have done I don't and I don't
think such a device meets the
federation's values which is I
appreciate that yeah yeah
you're allowed to disagree with me I
give you permission only slightly just a
slightly different perspective to a
point you know I'll tell you when you're
go
um but but I say I have no other issues
with the with the values I just don't
think it I don't think it expresses the
Star Trek's values particularly other
than you know what I'm changing my mind
a little bit Spock at the end with the
way he sacrifices himself is
is Star Trek values and actually Vulcan
values the needs the many out made the
needs the one yeah one so maybe I'm
being a bit
mean well you you know you're not it's
not cast in stone you can always to find
your uh your SCH I think you guys have
convinced me and I'm going to give it a
four as well which means I need to do my
math again at the end but never mind I
you've convinced me I've changed my mind
okay which I'm also allow to
do um
right uh John Campbell I love the the
fangi Genesis device without a pay wall
did you see that in in Lower Deck it was
good um when the Klingons heard about it
though they IM immediately went well
that was a fact it was a dangerous thing
from a from obviously the next movie
does focus on that as well yeah so yeah
that's well when we're gonna talk about
another time next film yeah um
humor uh humor
um yeah the bones ra um there was I
don't think humor was that prevalent in
this movie um the same as the first
movie uh I would say that the humor for
both is similar I'm trying to think of
some funny uh moments from Star Trek 2
which really made me think oh this is
funny um I don't think there is any no
I'm nothing's coming to mind thinking
about it straight off um I I've rate
I've given this a two just because
there's a few bits AR you dead at the
end of the kobashi Maru where um I think
is it is it McCoy says to spock aren't
you dead because they're doing the you
know the practice of the C that was a a
funny thing to say sorry K what say what
you gonna say about it mine's quite low
yeah I was that's a good point and
um K as Maru in this film k at the
beginning yeah K so kirst in this K's in
yeah
my brains a melt I've forgotten that but
so yeah that is that is a good bit of
course because he's on about how the no
win situations and then that comes back
in later Go full she's on she's in the
when she just the car but she's down
there with him um best uniforms in this
film by the way I me they they upgraded
the uniforms monster Maroons the monster
Maroons there is an inadvertently funny
bit in this movie and it it's always
awkward and everybody and do you know
which before I say it do you know what
I'm talking about what is it okay it is
Scotty playing the bag pipes at the end
when um yeah that's a bit with half a
finger exactly because he's got a finger
Miss yeah that was a bit I don't know
whether be class as a as a point I don't
think it can because it's against theual
humor um I've only ra I've given this a
two because I think there are a couple
of bits in it that
are um funny but not haha funny or or
the they're light you know what I mean
there's a few bits with um when for
example like when he um when Kirk's on
the thing and spot tells him we're ready
to go and and the son goes I thought you
said it was going to be days and he goes
ah now it's if you think the people are
listening but and but it's not funny but
it's it's nice it's it's a positive
thing and it but it's not like oh that's
so funny you know I'll probably give it
a two as well there isn't really any
humor in this no I'll give it a two as
well I know we get matching a lot of our
scores but you know when you ask the
question I really had to think about it
there's hardly any funny scenes at all
no it's just it's just not that's not
that's not what the film was about yeah
okay so the Scotty rating which is the
technology the science that we see in
the movie so
we have to really look at the
con um it's the Genesis device isn't it
I was going to say that the technology
of the movie obviously so we talked
about the morals of the technology now
let's think about the actual science how
the bloody hell did that weapon work
protomatter I've told you there we are
that's it that's all you need to know
it's protomatter you can't just make up
a word and go they did they did right so
but this thing held all the genetic
information so plants started to grow
immediately yeah and how was it deployed
every single species or no it was just
plants wasn't it I think it was just
plants then you have to
deposit forms but it's just mind you in
the in the next movie we do see an
evolution we do see life forms which are
evolving from yeah so there must be life
oh no because the um the life was
evolving it was oh no it was on the torp
germs on their feet andu on the torpedo
sorry you're right yeah yeah um it was
like yeah it was it was bacteria that
was
becoming it was just evolving very very
fast um but but plants were growing and
stuff and that didn't come and and water
was being created you can actually see
Lakes
growing maybe don't have as big a
problem with that though because it's
almost like replic it is actually just
fusing hydrogen and and oxygen so maybe
I could get away with that but the pl it
genetic information was somehow
being so it it made mountains and
stuff well there was a great simulation
in the one of the first CGI simulations
of the actual Genesis um project and you
see a baron Moon and it starts to as you
say you see like mountains are forming
atmospheres forming and it becomes a
whole planet in its own perspective but
as you say apart from them using
protomatter which was actually wasn't
that illegal wasn't that the thing they
said that like why did you it's so
unstable Oh no just very really really
unstable wasn't it and that was what
but wasn't it illegal why does that
sound familiar when it's illegal David
had to admit didn't he said I had to cut
Corners like um like like John just said
he had to cut Corners to get it to work
but one of the things I think he said he
had to use his Proto matter if I
remember right and that was how he he
was able to get around it but that was
what caused the problem that that that's
what he admitted in the third one isn't
it when everything started to break
basically when that's right he was
cutting corners and that that's why um
it all went wrong that's why it wasn't
actually that stable in the first place
because but it it planets building water
lakes forming oceans forming plants
start to grow instantly yeah no I'm
sorry it didn't make any logical sense
to me um it's basically like a massive
replicator but but why was it a a blast
with a shock wave and it just didn't
make any sense to me and also of course
one thing you got to remember is at the
end of the film we do see the new
genesis planet
with all the plants and trees and
jungles and things like that so as you
say but yeah it was only just plants
what it supposed to be M yeah that
makesense be transported afterwards it
was like it was the germs and the
bacteria that we saw yeah um the
Vulcan yeah I I just don't think
the technology for me made any sense at
all from the Genesis point of view so
it's not points down for me
but everything
else I thought was again stunning um I I
love the idea of the Genesis device yeah
I just don't think practically I can't
see it's practicality you've got an
issue with isn't it EXA It's Magic as as
I can tell yeah so
um o other technology in Star Trek like
the replicators and things I can
understand how that is possible is
taking atoms and putting them together
and using an energy F or whatever
but that I don't get but then I see
things like um I love the Grom it's it's
one of my favorite Starships I love that
[__] the over the top of brilliant um I
love the rest of the technology like the
warp drive and having to fix the warp
drive because the crystals and things
all that technology and stuff I think
was great so I've given it a three um
just because all the other Tech I
thought was great I just don't
understand the gen I I I'm a huge fan of
Star Trek starships and as you say the
Grom uh was the not Grom the Reliant no
Grom was the O birth class start his
started at three that's what I get mixed
up with
oh Reliance sorry I wanted to call the
Reliant
class yeah Miranda I can't believe
nobody in wor that's fine I nobody in
comment I normally get jumped on when I
make a mistake all right um but the
Miranda was such a lovely design it was
the first non Enterprise looking [__]
we'd ever seen in Star Trek which looks
like the Enterprise wasn't um and for
the technologically side of things I'll
would have to give the the film a four
just because of the of the Reliant it
was such a cool looking
ship around decad of Star Trek um and
that's a big that's a big thumbs up for
me and the configuration was copied as
well you know like there's even a TNG
style um and and everything and yeah
know love I always love if you're if
you're going to turn I mean the
Enterprise um a is my favorite
Enterprise probably and then and then
the Reliant is the E maybe the E is
beautiful but um I think the a might be
my my favorite Starship A's very why'
you like a more than Say the original
171 it's just a it just looks Le it's I
just think it's a nicer design it's
cleaner it
looks um more like a real Starship if
that makes sense but it's just it looks
like it's doing a million miles an hour
Stood Still okay um but I just think it
was yeah um like say where the busard
ram Scoops are um in the Enterprise the
the a the the round domes with the
circle things going around but in the in
the Enterprise a it was just more like
those those slits sort of things which
made it look I know I've never noticed
much of a difference between the
Enterprise 1701 movie and the Enterprise
a I thought they were pretty much a bulk
standard sorry the um the a is the
second class which is exactly the same
sorry the 1701 refit then so so the
total refit is the first which is the
enterprise we see in the movie The
Complete right that's what I'm saying
the refit class complete they're called
Constitution 2 I think it's called um
the Constitution two is actually the
new the vessel in Picard was the that's
Constitution three or NE is that I think
three you're on with the ships tonight I
tell
you it is it's also known as a neoc
constitution that pic yeah it is yeah
that's right yeah um yeah that's
interesting but anyway go back um the
reli was such a good ship and uh I'm
glad that it featured in Next Generation
DS9 I don't know if he saw it in bgia
you um right Memory Alpha says you're
wrong the Constitution to oh no no it
says I'm wrong that the constitution
class is the Heavy Cruiser is the refit
that's right Constitution yeah there you
go I used to be so good on all this
stuff but over the years over the last
10 years or so you got a life mate you
probably got a life it's like I don't
love Star Trek as much as I used to oh
well there's lots of other stuff to
watch like show with a big Round Disc
with um yeah that's that's something
Focus I tell you what I used to know the
and I probably can still pull bits of
information you know like when they had
the um Star Trek generation um technical
manual for the Enterprise D yeah I knew
that thing backwards and I used to play
Star Trek the quiz show did you ever
play that with John de oh it was great
and it was like it was asked all these
questions and I used to get most of them
right and he used to say I'm almost
impressed at the end of the game it was
really good that was really good
Rocco was just saying here that he likes
the Enterprise C was that the Ambassador
no that's my least favorite Enterprise I
don't like it you know they fat one I I
think the C looked fat it's all opinion
though I mean but it looked chunky to me
I never like I quite like the F actually
even though I haven't seen much of it
really I thought the f look quite cool
yeah I love the Odyssey class anyway but
Odyssey Odyssey yeah I'm questioning
myself with everything
here um but yeah so
yeah so four yeah but I know we could
talk Starships all night we must move on
only got 15 minutes no that's we'll do
an episode just talking about ships
maybe next time up for that I love I
really I'll be right there if you up to
do I'll get all the photos up and
everything if you guys want yeah yeah
I'll just tell you about it without even
looking up I'm so sad about [__]
Stanley's thrown in there you've already
you've already corrected us but yeah the
gr is from the search to spock 100%
right I can't believe I made that
mistake but I know I got it from
somewhere I watched The Search for Spock
yesterday today so it must just stuck in
my brain I love that um I'm ahead
because I'm thinking about the next
video already anyway the hura rating for
writing uh yeah it's well written it's
well written movie I've gone five out of
five I think it's there is no issues
with the script at all as far as I'm
concerned yeah I think I'll give it the
same I mean it's it is one of the most
popular Star Trek movies um everything
about the actual characterization the
ideas um all right some of the ideas
we've already talked about which might
be a little bit of a stretch but um for
what it is it is still one of the most
successful and most well-liked Star Trek
movies ever after 13 movies so yeah
writing Wise It's Gonna be high up there
yeah some of the writing is Iconic
though I mean that even people aren't
Star Trek fans
know when Spock is against the glass
yeah and then you know Kirk puts his
hands against you are and always will be
my friend that's how they tried to
replicate it with the star Tre into
darkness which we'll be talking about at
some point in the future where okay I
won't even go there yeah it was
um we I I I'm not going to be very kind
about that movie at times even though I
do really really like bits of it yeah I
like the Vengeance I don't hate any any
Tre movie I mean you know there are bits
of some track movies I dislike but
dancing in Star Tre 5 wasn't very good
there are bits in Star Trek 5 that are
terrible but there are bits in Star Trek
5 that are bloody brilliant as well so
let's not we won't be mean to it but uh
anyway yeah the
visuals um I I have absolutely no issue
with any the visuals in this movie five
yeah um as well um I just think it's an
absolutely stunning looking movie and I
think they're both it's amazing amazing
it's 41 years old which is
it it really and and the A and the music
is fantastic this is the first um wasn't
Jerry gold smith who was James Herer
James Herer did the music and the music
was absolutely fantastic with the
visuals as well with the ship scenes in
the in the yeah oh God no it's really
really good visually um you can't fault
it no not an not at all right 10 16 20
27 divided by
equals 3.85 I've scored this somehow
slightly higher than you how have I done
that oh okay I thought that was a pretty
oh yeah the Spock rating it was just the
Spock
rating
3.8 so my um my renb rating for this
movie is a solid four out of five yours
is
3.85 wow out of five which is not bad
though compared to what was it like last
week 2.12 and 2.5 five so it's done
better yes so got two questions to end
out on for one um I think it was Bob
said earlier um I was never worried Star
Trek isn't Science Fiction it's merely
pop
sci-fi um my instinct there was of
course it isn't science fiction what you
on about but does Bob actually have a
point because a lot of Star Trek
uses theories and things that are
popular
at the time and then runs with it and
does a story about it so this movie
terraforming was something that was
being thought about seriously as a new
science we could we could terraform Mars
no we can't it hasn't got a magnetic
field you can terraform it all you like
solar winds will blow it away I'm sorry
it just will um but terraforming was you
know and that's where this that's
probably where this movie came from
terraform is thing let's do a weapon
that does it
instantly
TNG was
particularly
um to did this a lot that they would do
theories in science and they would do it
they would run with it and do an episode
and and then all things I'm not quite
sure they've understood
that they as you say I mean the fact is
that although they had some scientific
advisers and uh Consultants involved um
some of the ideas were they've heard
about something what can we do in a
Sci-Fi premise yeah um and uh some of
these um ideas worked better than others
um going back to this movie of course
like I said the Genesis ultimate
terraforming in Click a finger and
that's it you've got a brand new planet
with the right amount of temperature the
right amount of water the right you know
that is that is more sort of fantasy I
think than science fiction in many ways
it's it's it's too it's a bit too it's
probably one of the although the film
still work so well it's probably one of
the most negative aspects of it from a
scientific background you know I mean
I'm not a scientist but um like I said
you have to start thinking about you
know this would never ever happen but
then I suppose you could say that about
you
know might have lost mic there for a
second I think he's going to say though
that you can say that about a lot of
science nowadays
that it's just that it's beyond our
ability to comprehend you know as you
talked to somebody 200 years ago and
explain to the microwave back at some
point yeah okay um you know it's
possible in the future there might be
some new kind of fast and light travel
you know in the end you got to get the
right balance I mean this is why some
people just don't like science fishing
because they say well this is ridiculous
and why would they do that and I think
you got to be quite open-minded to watch
science fiction to to a degree you got
think okay it's probably not GNA happen
but it might do as something you
explained um a mobile phone to somebody
40 years ago and they'll shoot you for
being a witch yeah yeah I mean I I used
um today I was I went around to my mom's
and um she um was talking about poetry
and stuff like that and I just opened up
chat gp2 and I just said oh make a poem
about whatever it was and literally in
about five seconds she it works out and
she's terrified of the future she's one
those people that looks to the Past than
to the Future I'm fascinated with all
that I'm a bit scared about it because
this is becoming science fact yeah but
like I said science fiction although it
gets a lot of stuff wrong can get stuff
right as well that's well I mean with
Star Trek I think they just go with some
things that are popular because you know
when Quantum stuff because of Stephen
Hawkins so Quantum engineering quantum
mechanics started to get into the
popular culture so everything was
quantum yes for a bit um and Star Trek
was to blame for that a little bit and
then nanites nanites with the
r robots and stuff yeah yeah so um they
been guilty of that so I do think it's
but I do think all science fiction does
that to a degree because it is fiction
as well yeah you know it's not science
fact it's not a
documentary it's not Galaxy Quest that's
definitely a documentary because it's
true it's it's science fiction so there
is an element of fiction there but but
yeah I I I I don't think it's a an
unfair comment Bob
I think I think it's a little bit unfair
but not not not totally it's inter to
talk about it I mean there's a fair
enough like I said that question is fair
enough I mean the expanse or something
like that is more science fiction You
could argue more sciency but it's a
little bit more science what about um
like Foundation that's another one which
is quite heavy going a lot of
spiritualism and stuff in that fantasy
is it's not quite um i' say it is
science fiction as well but there's a
lot of spirituality and things like that
in there so it's um there's a there's
there's a lot of that going on but yeah
it's not a straight up sci-fi I mean the
really you can argue something like the
Martian or something is is the only
thing that's closer to science fiction
but it could be science reality in just
like 20 years Martian was a very very
well put together film I you say it was
much more based on sci's facts or POS or
Clos to what could be a fact than some
of the stuff in made a couple of
mistakes but nothing major the other
question I'm going to ask them is going
back to Star Trek The Wrath of KH okay
is this the best of the Star Trek
movies for
me no only because first of all I've
seen it so many
times um and also because there's a lot
of movies out there with different cast
and stuff like that I I think generally
speaking it is the best of the Star Trek
movies but I think for on an individual
basis I just happen to like some of the
others just personally just something
about them clicks with me more than this
movie but how about you I mean what do
you think about
that I think it's probably the most
iconic of all the films I think it's the
film that non trekkies know accessible
the best of although apparently start 4
was quite accessible as well when we get
to that yeah I think the Voyage Home is
is pretty accessible
um
I think there's there's bits of this
film I I think this is Star Trek at its
best but I do think there's a Trilogy of
movies here for me
with these three films are the best we
got St Tre I think with this the Search
for Spock and the Voyage Home which were
always conceived as a as three films
they run off each other really nicely
um I I I don't think we've ever had
better um the WRA of
KH it's definitely up there
you I I I couldn't I'm not going to say
it's the best of them but it's
it's it when it's star trekked it's best
it's it's the these three films that and
you can tell that because they've
emulated them so many times and copied
them so many times and not just I mean
Star Trek itself Paramount itself has
copied I think we just last week no um
Wrath of KH has been copied about four
times yeah um really you can argue Star
Trek Nemesis is really just a copy of of
um the wrath of KH just they just
swapped KH for a genetic engineered
version of himself and I I you know I
haven't really thought about that but I
think that's a fair enough um parallel
actually that was observation does make
sense that there a character yeah the
battle at the end very similar
yeah um the the the battle in the nebula
has been replicated several times you
know it's like but but not just by other
other films
you this is a little familiar but I mean
it's such a basic premise though isn't
it of of Revenge you know who doesn't
like a good Revenge plot well what I
would say is the problem with science
fiction is if you've seen as much as I
have and you probably have as well in
the end you are going to watch things
and think oh I saw an episode of
Stargate that had that exact similar
storyline think of you know and uh it's
just the nature of the fact that you
know there's only a limitation to how
many basic stories are out there but
they people have their own slot their
own way of making it slightly different
and that's that's just the nature of the
of the genre I think you know somebody
actually on Twitter the other day um
said that um one of one of the Brad
Wright's episodes of Stargate where um
the sg1 is plugged into a
um it's like oh the gatekeeper the the
no the yeah the Dwight reality anyway
yeah yeah they're plugged into V and he
said oh it's so ahead of its time and so
and and somebody else went no that that
story's been done before and they were
getting quite ATT and and actually Brad
R even said I'm not going to pretend
that that's not original we might have
done something a little bit original
with it but it's been done before and I
had to point out that actually there's a
movie there's a book in 1946 written
about how somebody was got plugged into
virtual reality and um the very early
computers were just being sort of
theorized and somebody wrote this book
um so it was it's not an original story
then you got like lawn mower man from
the late 80s early 90 lawn man yeah
that's another example same thing so um
but but but Brad even had to correct
this guy like it was just a big fan he
just loves star gameing I was just like
saying like it's so so ahead of his time
which it was there was a Stargate Star
Trek parallel the one I always think
about is it was a both of them involved
a Space
Race and um Voyager had Kim and Paris
and they had to have a space race and
then on on Stargate they had a space
race as well I can't remember who's in
it but I think um an actor was actually
appeared in stars in that episode as
well and those two episodes were very
very similar and I seem to remember them
they're both being on at a similar time
as well around about
1998 99 near the end of bour season no
it would have been 200 one and starget
then was probably in about season five
season six and both the episodes was
like they both literally copied it off
each other so you always wonder whether
it's just a coincidence or whether one
was reference from the other one um the
novel I was talking about John just in
case you're interested it's not a it's
not a um Philip KD dick story it was
called Pig marlean spectacles there
there's a character there Professor
invented a pair of goggles that um gave
you sight sound smell and basically
absor abbed you into virtual reality
it's like an Oculus but with spell and
it was written in 1935 by Stanley weine
bound sounds like a visor thing for the
eyes so um this astonish astonish um but
yeah no I I would agree with you
basically
that's but anyway I mean um I suppose we
wrap things up soon but I I will say
that though that um you know
um because there one thing we don't
actually mention is the but I think
James hor is one of the best musicians
in the Star Trek um I like Dennis
McCarthy from the Star Trek next
Generation here I like some of his music
and he did generations and of course
Jerry gosmith but I think James Herer
was he did this one and the Search for
Spock I don't know whether they did the
music for the Voyage Home I think he
might have done actually I can't
remember but that was going back to the
trilogy of these three films um I think
that's one thing that also made the
films so much more more significant it's
just the the musical scores were so nice
that Then followed through into TNG
which is one of the reasons I think TNG
was just lovely because the music I love
the music style and everything was very
similar and um that was the film because
we saw the tg's theme tune we actually
see in one of the the movies don't I
can't remember which one is it um um
it's in one of the one of the Kirk
movies first might be Undiscovered
Country oh
country was after TNG what you mean the
actual theme tune yeah the actual score
for that's that's the motion picture the
motion pitch did it first and then the
next Generation took it in
1987 um from obviously Jerry gold smith
which was always strange Road that's the
best that's the best one
obviously that's been a
long time time is finally
um my Christmas song comes out tomorrow
guys by the way so don't forget so if
you want to listen to me sing we should
do a duet we should get the actual
lyrics and to sing sing that Bloody song
that um faith of the heart song that'd
be funny that be there we go we'll do
that um I've actually done two songs now
I enjoyed doing the so so tomorrow comes
the 12 days of Stargate oh okay tell me
about this um so um I tell I'll tell you
the first line is on the first day of
Stargate Brad W gave to me that time Sam
blew up a star on the second day of
Stargate Brad W gave to me two Jack oals
and that time Sam blew up a star and
that's all I'm that's god um but it goes
on and there just 12 you should actually
mix s some music do it properly I have
that might be fun I have done oh okay
I'll tell you what I'll I'll I'll play
you a clip I can play a okay that's and
but then I've also done a jingle bells
version is the ultimate sci-fi Jingle
Bells
song right um and it's um it starts with
um basically I basically say reality TV
it's not for me I'd much rather watch
the Sci-Fi then goes on like
that yeah okay instead of Jingle Bells
it's sg1 Atlantis Stargate
Universe but you know the guy I've
talked about before who sings he's made
the lyrics for all the Star Trek and
Stargate Series yeah and I don't oh I
have to send you link to those because
they are hilarious that this guy he just
makes up the lyrics to The Next
Generation theme or sg1 or Atlantis and
they're very very funny to watch and we
have features on that on my channel
quite a few
times I can't play it a why not play a I
haven't got it um oh I've got it on
patreon I can play it on patreon
okay a my m just said he doesn't want to
do beers tonight so I'm not in a rush
now I was going to um I supposed to be
rushing out to meet him and he's just
said he doesn't want to go oh what you
said is it is it because of what we've
been saying is it have you s like no
he's literally said he's only just go
back from work I think so all right
where is it come on I want to play it
now that I a but now you don't have to
rush you can look you can take your time
finding it see yeah memberships no oh
hang on maybe we can find this guy that
does the songs
okay um right here we go 12 days of
[Music]
Stargate going to go Roy
cheat look at that voice of an Angel
voice of an Angel
sir
[Music]
that's all you're getting oh BL me
that's good so how you you do all
yourself then yeah you're quite good you
got a dab hand at all that sort of stuff
then Matt I to teach me a little bit
I've done a bit Mi to myself but I uh
yeah okay well we look forward are you
going at the end of the obviously when
that's out tomorrow because it's 12 days
until Christmas tomorrow and then the
Jingle Bells one will come out next week
are you going to try and release this as
a sort of proper song and and I'm going
to release it it's going to be on Apple
and I will be number one [__] you Mar
yeah exactly um no I'm not doing that
I'm
just um but it's it's a fun little silly
little thing just for just for you guys
uh I put it on patreon yesterday and
Dave G immediately he messaged back
going my dog weird my dog won't stop
barking which is doubly weird because I
haven't got a dog it's like you
bastard my channel what we're going to
do is we do a Christmas message and
Martin and I are going to do a sort of
Doctor Who Regeneration thing but we're
going to do it in the style of I won't
give the spoilers if you not seen it but
something really happened on the on the
specials over the weekend it's been a
massive thing but I W going to tell you
because obviously some you won't know
but what happened on the episode we're
going to try and do it with some CGI and
visuals and green screen stuff so it
probably look terrible but we'll give it
a
go yeah um I'm I'm certain to be good
and I know what you're talking about
we've already talked about it on the
channel so if anybody doesn't know we
talked about it at the live on Sunday
and half through the conversation went
spoilers and three or four that's why
really careful not to say anything you
know what I mean yeah some somebody a
IMM went thanks very much for the
spoilers dick bit late there aren you
sorry
um what did you think about I I tell you
what don't worry about spoil well
spoilers the doctor splits into do and
David Tenant isn't dead yeah your
thoughts because I thought
it it was
odd um it was a bit of a cop out but I
feel first of all I I did quite like the
new guy I thought the new guy he had a
red energy about himself and I just
thought he was pretty good um and he had
a and the music was great in the episode
as well and um Neil Patrick Harris was
in it he was really good um
but you know it's David Tenant never
seems to want to leave the series does
he he's always sort of hanging on there
and technically now we've got two David
Tenant sort of doctors out there we've
got the one which is human with rose in
Another Universe and now we've got the
14th doctor still alive I don't know I I
yeah go on he can just come back
whenever he wants techically because
they're just going to get if if the
popularity starts waning again he'll
come back and re refuel it
you're St the fire again there's got to
be a plan for that there's going to have
to there's there's there's a plan in
there there's got to be an episode where
they're going to both be in it again
there got to be although this is the one
historical fact that nobody else has
actually referenced apart from me but
this episode is the episode where we
actually say goodbye to the original
Tardis because shoy he gets in the
duplicate Tardis and tenant keeps the
original so in the future we'll always
beting the copy Tardis not the original
not that it's a big deal but and it's
also got a dukee box as well yeah it was
all right it was okay I'm gonna go with
it was okay at best yeah more I'm not
talking about what was it Bobo said ear
about pop culture there was no I mean
Doctor Who's always had a fast and loose
relationship with um science anyway yeah
but
um then just going well the rules of
game is still in action isn't it so I'm
just going to hit the tius with a hammer
and oh look we've got two yay very
fantasy
why no explanation yeah energy of the
toy maker yeah I know I still liked it I
thought it was good it was right um and
when they split it I was just I was
hoping one of them would be evil you
know I like how Superman in Superman 3
when he spit and one of them got all the
crap one of them got the thing I was
like why isn't one of these evil what or
separated it and one of them Danny Dev
Vito you
know that would have been way better but
no well like I said I think it was it
was an interesting way they went um I
will be watching the next series um and
of course the tius has also gotten out a
disabled disability ramp as well so
there you go yeah um
I don't like Doctor Who
I know this is why you talked about it
so long yeah I know I know I loved it
tenant first time around and then Matt
Smith loved it I watched it every year I
watched every episode and then I gave up
on it and I'm trying to watch it again
now I'm thinking oh while the original
writ is back maybe I'll enjoy it and I'm
like I'm sick to death of being you know
like people go I don't like being
preached to being preached to and this
woke this is a bit preachy yeah I I
don't like to mention the W word but it
it is quite prevalent these days in a
lot of things and and the new Doctor Who
you know we you know the Davos thing we
all know about the Davos we can't look
like Davos anymore because he depicts a
a person with a wheelchair as being evil
which I think is the most ridiculous
thing I've ever heard but um in the end
um you know you just have to sort of uh
try to filter it out and watch it for
what it is I once got punched in the
dick by a guy in a wheelchair he was
evil
so well that's a way to finish a show
isn't it yeah Pricks all shapes and
sizes mate you always think the old
people oh Isn't She Lovely just dearly
old person no old people can be [__]
too oh yeah disabled people can be [__]
anybody can be a [__] and this guy
punched me in the dick and he was a
[__] um so you elaborate was it
something you said or
what um I was I was kind of caring for
him so no it's right I I took him out on
to the motor and reeled him into the
middle left him there and then run off
so it's all good really it's okay it's
all I got my I got my revenge um but
yeah see you uh but no he was he was he
wasn't very well but he was just um he
was he was angry so he decided to take
it out on my penis which sounded wrong
actually that sounded right in my brain
but came out yeah I wouldn't tell people
too many people that story I think theyd
be giving you looking like what it goes
back to um it goes back to bosses and
stuff like that people you work with
with environments where you know you can
have some great environments and you get
one person who just doesn't fit in and
it can throw the dynamic of a working
practice um and it's it's a real pain
when you have that because you know in
the end you if you just work with each
other Just go with it and you know we
all have issues from time to time but
you get that one person who really just
is a thorn in your side and makes
difficult for everybody it just makes
the whole environment so much harder to
be to be in and that deal with so i'
I've been in that place before you have
a team you just got one person that's
negative everybody's everybody gets
tensed everyone's gets a bit like it
just changes it it's so
weird it is I worked in an office years
ago and there's this one woman who's
just such a b we got to a point where we
wouldn't look at each other even though
we sat next to each other basically if
we passed each other in town center both
just look at the floor I don't really
dislike anyone I'm quite yeah quite in
the in the thing is going to be shocked
by this but I am relatively
friendly uh most of the time um I don't
dis but if I dislike somebody I it it
becomes like vengeful I'm I'm a real I'm
I'm a s if I don't if I don't like you
you'll know I don't like you and it is
there is a thing this is I don't s so
I'm not worried at the moment in respect
of what we're doing on our channels
together we're fine good we're good um
if if I really dislike we wouldn't have
spoken more than
on but it takes it takes a lot for me to
dislike so to really dislike somebody um
and I find actually that if it's
somebody I really dislike it's probably
because they're a bit like me oh D you
think there's too much of with okay I I
I'm not a big fan of my brother-in-law
shh don't tell anyone um no everyone
knows he doesn't like me either but I've
have always wonder because we're
actually quite similar and we I think we
dislike the things in each other that we
dislike about myself sort of thing we're
both a bit I'm I'm a little bit arrogant
I try not to be but I am I think I know
best and um do you do you um what I what
I iniversity do is you when you meet
people and we all do this without even
thinking it you automatically evaluate
them to a degree and work out what
they're about and whether what you're
going to get out of them which we
shouldn't do but it's human nature it's
just what we do and I think that
um brain works yeah and some you should
do that but sometimes you just can't
help it so you know but um but yeah so
um but yeah I was just say that this
this woman I worked with though got to
the point where I remember one of the
days she wasn't in somebody somebody be
me went you can tell somebody's not in
can't you and we were like
you with the accent I love the accent
you can tell what it can't
you um I just think it's one of those
things that um you know like you can you
can cut the tension with a knife but it
actually it's like a tangible tension
somebody when somebody isn't is is there
and it's like it's
strange isn't it it's like a sort of in
the room um and I don't know why that is
but uh what's this oh you got something
on in two minutes what's that man united
are playing and we're already apparently
losing six nil a Dave is joking but it's
only one minute in and Kane has already
shot across goal and nearly Miss well as
long as you don't say anything about my
beloved Manchester City that's all
that's all that
matters I didn't know you're in
Manchester City I'm no I'm just joking
mying hovering over the um edit the
remove
button I'm not a football fan I know
you're into football I'm not into
football but I know that there's a
there's a rivalry isn't there there's a
rivalry righte
Mike shoot off one thing I'll quick show
you if you seen the I was looking at
that fella do you know what it is that's
a policeman no it is the cookie jar from
the
office I never really watch the office I
you never see the office I I have seen
it but not I've got that from the office
stop move away from the cookie jar there
you go that's my to show off very good
that's going to impress all your
subscribers isn't it I can see your
Advent calendar as well which is good oh
yeah thanks very much been a good one um
when do you fany you coming back for the
next one we'll do it about next three or
four weeks again maybe we'll first week
Christmas after week Christmas maybe and
yeah we do it around about that sort of
time don't Starships video somewhere in
between maybe yeah okay I'm actually I'm
a free over Christmas so if you want to
do one special different one on
Starships I'd love to do that because I
i' would love to talk about that let's
do that let's let's find a day um I
actually am working most of Christmas
but we I'm sure we can find something
yeah yeah just let me know what fits in
with you and I'll go with it that'd be
great I look forward to doing that we'll
do it live again we'll be in touch all
right then thank you Mike um guys
everybody thanks again for getting in
the audience Legend thank you for
checking us out um
and yeah uh let me just find the um off
one have a good night guys we'll see you
I think probably see you live tomorrow
actually um I don't can't remember why
but I think I'm live again tomorrow um
and we'll be back Mike in a couple of
weeks and the my. two review will be out
on Thursday on my channel don't forget
to go over to code clud if you are a you
Sid tracker and go check him out and if
you're watching on code clud um go check
out Sidetrack because you know vice
versa absolutely need need subscribers
so
bye
[Music]
guys